you know what i think in quarantine i
realized that
i'm not really a rapper i'm an artist i
like to write out my goals
and i always like visualize where i see
myself going
and it's just like i feel like the
platform that i'm that i'm
building for myself it's just bigger
than in
rapping like especially with me singing
more like it's just going to turn me
into a different type of artist
i spend them back to the streets
you just dropped back to the streets
featuring janae
aiko did you know that fans actually
created a change.org position for you to
release this song i did grow they're
wild
they've been trying to bully me into
getting to share it but you know
everything
takes time it takes preparation
so i'm just so happy we waited for this
moment because now it's special
and the visual is coming out soon it
feels good but i feel like what makes
back to the street so special
is it doesn't sound like anything else
that's out right now
it's a different approach at least for
me when it comes to
rapping you know i love someone said i
had a man voice that's okay i love my
deep voice
and normally i'm super aggressive but
this is more girly more melodic
i'm still popping my but it's just a
different
layer to sweetie as an artist
right okay so we got tap in we got the
remix and also
pretty [ __ ] freestyle was that the
reason why you felt like this was the
next
best single to drop ahead of your debut
album
yeah i think it i think it is i'm just
letting the people know that sweetie
will be singing more
i feel like me dropping my songs me
campaigning for pretty rich music so i'm
just letting the people know
what to expect when the album finally
comes out
yes so have you been taking singing
lessons or have you always been able to
sing but you just haven't you know shown
that side of you
where does that come from actually i
used to sing in a choir
um i have like an also voice which is
why
um the singing lessons i have been
taking have been paying off because this
is definitely a higher note for me
um but yeah i've always wanted to be a
singer i wanted to be a singer before i
was a rapper but
you know when i was a little girl mariah
carey was out
aliyah was out and i was like they could
sing right
i could sing like drake so
um you know practice makes perfect i've
been i'm currently in boot camp right
now um
i've been dancing i've been working out
i've been taking vocal lessons
i've been doing a whole bunch of mood
boards so i'm in like an intense
artist camp right now yeah i love that i
mean that gives me the chills because
it's like wow you're already
great at what you do you know but you
have so much more potential
that really we're really about to see
which is cool it's dope thank you
yeah so let's talk about janae for a
second what was the process like getting
her
on this song um
the process you know what's so
interesting about being in quarantine
normally you're able to run into people
a lot and you're like hey i want you on
this this and that but in quarantine
we're not able to interact like that so
my team knows her
team um i've always been a fan of her
since my college days
she definitely has soundtracks to
moments in my life yes
psep she's she's dropped so i think it's
an exciting moment we're both from the
west coast
we're both asian so there's a lot of
common denominators that makes this
this um collab make sense
well timbaland he produced the song and
i mean he's been in this game
for years and he's legendary of course
what's the most important
lesson you've learned from him working
with him so far
um i feel like
when it's you i'm pretty sure when you
get compliments
like you don't realize what good you're
doing for yourself
yeah until somebody else says it
especially somebody whose opinion holds
weight
i remember when i was working with him
he told me that
he appreciated how hands-on how
thoughtful
how i work but because i it's me i'm not
realizing
what my work ethic is so i kind of held
on to those
those compliments that he gave me and i
started to pay attention
to them and i started to hone in on them
because i'm like okay if he notices them
and if he if he's saying that this is
what makes
my work great then i'm going to continue
doing these things that
are great that's smart that's a really
smart move
okay so let's talk about the album
specifically when can fans
get the album everybody you know i know
things have been pushed back pushed back
but
do you have some sort of idea when we
can finally hear it
so i know girl i know
honestly the date the season the month
keeps changing
so i would just say soon um
whoever has been supporting me genuinely
supported me the girls
who and the boys who have stuck with me
through thin and thin
through good viral moments through even
bad
viral moments they are going to be
really proud to be a part of this team
when they see these visuals these
singles and especially when the album
comes out like it's a great moment to be
an icy gang member
so yeah i'm just really excited to just
share what i've been working on
because i don't preview a lot of things
and i know that i'm i'm getting you know
my foot back into the game because you
know it took me a year to release
something since my
fight but i haven't just been you know
getting my nails done
putting on bomb outfits being funny you
know because i've been
i've been very proactive on like triller
and tiktok
but i've been i've been strategizing and
sometimes they're like
where are you at girl we haven't seen
you on instagram or twitter but i'm like
i'm working
i'm a silent shooter i don't like i mean
people work differently
and my work ethic is you know i'm an
assassin i'ma come out and shoot me and
meet you and go hear that
so right let the work speak for itself
at the end
exactly so what are you most proud of
when it comes to this body of work
what what have you walked away and been
like okay like i did that like this is
what i can just
you know hold up and be proud of
i think singing yeah i think singing
there's there's moments where like i'll
cut a singing track but then i'll come
back three weeks later to see if my
voice improved
but i'm really just testing you know i
didn't realize how much of
how much of an instrument your voice is
like
like if like i didn't because when i
think of playing with my voice i thought
of like
cartoon extreme things but sometimes
it's not even that
sometimes you're just changing the tone
literally just the tone not being
animated just a tone so
i think i'm just i'm really exploring
what it is
to use my voice as a vocal vessel
in an instrument yeah well you could
tell you're learning because i'm
learning from you i'm like really
okay like i'm going to try to all right
because
if it was up to me i'd rap i would i
would just rap
aggressive and just hard all the time
but it's just like
i've been reflecting a lot more too and
i feel like when you're in a creative
when you're a creative you constantly
have to reflect so that you can keep
reinventing yourself
so i'm just like okay i can't rap like
that all the time so what i want what do
i want to do like how can i show
show the world a different side of
sweetie by still being true to my brand
so that's something that i've been
working on
yeah well you mentioned in an interview
that because of quarantine you and your
team have been
swapping out songs because you keep
getting better and better
in what ways do you feel like you've
developed as an artist or singing that
that major one um
i've developed in a during quarantine
during coin teams specifically because i
feel like we're all going to be able to
walk away and say okay i became better
for sure in this area
you know what i think in quarantine i
realized that
i'm not really a rapper i'm an artist
because when i'm like
i like to write out my goals and i
always like visualize where i see myself
going and it's just like i feel like the
platform that i'm
that i'm building for myself is just
bigger than
than in rapping like especially with me
singing more like it's just going to
turn me into a different type of artist
right so um i've just been really
focused on artist development because i
needed it
there's a lot of room for improvement
i'm still growing so
just a lot of reflection i really um
i really suggest reflecting for anybody
who's watching right now because
sometimes you have to take a moment
and step outside yourself to see what
you're doing great what can you
improve on because we work so much in
because everything is so much from real
time especially with social media
everything is instant
we really don't take time to just look
in the mirror and just sit still put
your phone down and sit in silence and
really look at yourself
right really look at yourself in and
and just reflect on things that you like
things that you don't like
rooms for improvement things that are
your your strong suits like
when you do that it kind of makes like
the vision clearer
and i'm all about having a clear vision
because any time i said i would do
something i've done it
so like writing it down of course no i
don't be tweeting everything i feel like
when you when you keep it in your
in your trusted circle or when you write
it down that's when it really comes
that's when it really comes to fruition
like i told myself
i would be an artist one day i told
myself i would get to usc
i told myself i would get a new car i
told myself that i would be able to take
care of me and some other people so it's
just like whenever you keep those
affirmations and you remind yourself
then the journey and the vision just
becomes clearer and clearer
yeah and that's what i love about you as
an artist because it's so
it's so clear how you are able to
manifest and just speak into existence
the things that you want to bring about
even from that j
cole video where you were rapping to him
you know and then we all know your story
about wanting to go to usc
and i think other than enjoying your
music that's what people
feed off of you know that's the real
gift you can give your fans is like
i did this you can do it too right right
and that's what i do want to show people
because even if you don't want to be a
musician right
if you want to be a politician or if you
want to be held a sales clerk i mean
whatever floats your boat
yeah as long as you write it down and
you're working every day to attain that
goal you will achieve it like everything
that i said i was going to do i really
did it
so i just i just hope to keep inspiring
those who are watching because
um i'm really a clear testament to show
that if i could do it you could do it
too
yeah and i think people get caught up on
the action part like they get afraid of
the hard work but the hard work really
is
easy once you write it down and once
you're clear it's like it
all just forms together and you're there
when you need to be you know
definitely okay so let's get back into
the album before we switch lanes a
little bit
so besides tapping and back to the
streets do you have another song that
you can tease
that you love and we could you know just
when the album comes out we can
definitely go to it and say like okay
this is the one she recommended
um oh girl you that's a good one that's
a great question my head
my my thoughts is like swimming through
my head right now
there's a song called prada and i really
love it just because
we're talking about affirmations but
it's like a
i want to call it it's icy girl 2.0 not
sound
wise not beat wise but it's icy girl 2.0
because i always tell people like i see
girls not rap full of affirmations
so prayed up is is like
you're able to relate to it because it's
important to be at least in my opinion
to be prayed up when you're going out to
to execute those affirmations or to live
in those affirmations or to
to just be living in your affirmational
moment i don't even know if that's the
word but it makes sense with that
sentence yes
but prayed up is just it's one of those
records that you can play every morning
to get your day started i love it
that's exciting so look we're gonna be
able to do what twerk
have a great time right and it's just
like
that's what i love about my brand i feel
like people who
people who don't understand it are the
people who are the critics but when you
really look at the brand like
i'm a human so there's there's levels of
inspiring there's
levels of me popping my there's levels
of me being a boss at levels of me
getting rational with me and my own
girls
yeah it's just like i'm a human being
and all these things make me human like
i have different lanes i have different
modes she's like i even got different
personalities girl
right look i'm every woman okay
whitney houston no i feel you so i think
that
pretty [ __ ] music is definitely it's
like you know how do you wash shrek
yeah i'm an onion and there's layers to
this
[Laughter]
white shrek
he told a donkey he was like i'm an
onion you gotta peel back players and i
feel like
just everything that i've been releasing
whether it's sick
i'll be having the weirdest analogies
there with me um
tick tock even with my icy life episodes
like people will get to know me
literally like i'm not just somebody who
comes out the gate hella transparent
sharing every bit of my life
and you definitely have to like get to
know me not like to know me is to love
me and everybody who knows me
really do love me so yeah you're like
the home girl
everybody wants to have right oh girl
well you know i come
i got from a family i come from a family
of women who is just hella loving and
supportive
anybody who comes around feels that love
not like that's where i get it from and
it's not even something that i try to do
which is something that i am it's
because
because that's where i come from so
that's why i try to give through my
music because we all need love and not
everybody
was fortunate to come from a village
like mine so i feel like
i try to share that love and inspiration
through my music
i love that okay well you know i have to
ask this next question because people
want to know
can we expect a feature from quavo
on this album what can you tell us girl
we shall see
he actually has a song in mind we just
both been working
so we will see i think what's great
about cuevo is
you know he raps and he sings we did
tiptoes
one thing that i will share is i was
talking to him about it
i really want to do something r b with
him like
like almost like a duet like everything
everything is about
pushing the limit and getting outside of
my comfort zone for pretty [ __ ] music
so i'm like baby if we do something
we gotta take it like let's let's take
it above tiptoes you know let's really
explore our artistic sides
are you thinking like avon and kiki
wyatt
what's that i mean of course of course
not thinking like kiki why because we
all know she got a voice voice right
like
oh oh she tries to i got my voice for it
no i didn't say that you said it
yourself
look i'm quiet
she's on a whole nother level okay but
what were you thinking something like
that
um i don't know we really just have to
see what what we cook up because i
definitely think it's a
it'll be like a 12 or like 14 or maybe
even a 16 hour session i want to start
from scratch i want to bring in the
producers i want to bring in live
instruments and really have it be a
musical moment